>> Tucker: ELIZABETH WARREN’S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN, THE MOST
ANNOYING ON RECORD, EXPIRED SOME
TIME AGO BUT SHE REMAINS TO
LECTURE AMERICA AND YOU,
SPECIFICALLY ON YOUR
SHORTCOMINGS.
HER LATEST CRUSADE INSPIRED BY
THE CORONAVIRUS IS AN ABSOLUTE
DEMAND FOR NATIONWIDE MAIL IN
VOTING.
>> WHAT’S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
SHOWS US EXACTLY WHY WE NEED A
PLAN FOR VOTING SAFELY DURING A
PANDEMIC.
THERE IS A SIMPLE SIX TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO AMERICAN WILL HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN VOTING AND
KEEPING THEMSELVES SAFE AND
HEALTHY.
ALL STATES SHOULD ALLOW
AMERICANS TO VOTE BY MAIL.
IT’S EASY TO VOTE BY MAIL.
AND IN ADDITION THERE SHOULD BE
ONLINE REGISTRATION.
EXTENDED REGISTRATION DEADLINES
AND EXPAND EARLY VOTING.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS KIND OF
REASONABLE.
THEY ARE LESS REASONABLE OVER ON
MSNBC WHERE ONE GUEST ARGUED IF
YOU DON’T WANT MAIL IN VOTING,
YOU ARE A MURDERER.
>> THIS THING IN WISCONSIN IS
ONE OF THE MOST AWFUL THINGS
I’VE SEEN IN MY LIFE.
JUST KNOW THE EXTENT THEY WILL
GO TO TO HOLD ON THE POWER.
IT’S ALL ABOUT ONE SUPREME COURT
SEAT, AND THEY WILL KILL PEOPLE
TO STAY IN POWER, LITERALLY.
>> Tucker: LITERALLY.
LITERALLY KILL PEOPLE.
THAT’S YOUR PLAN
ELIZABETH WARREN, YOU ARE
LITERALLY KILLING PEOPLE.
LITERALLY, YOU HAVE BLOOD ON
YOUR HANDS.
SO EVERYONE’S AFRAID AND
EVERYONE’S RETHINKING THINGS,
WONDERING IF WE SHOULD DO IT IN
A NEW WAY.
AND THAT’S OKAY, WE SHOULD BE
OPEN-MINDED.
WHY HAVEN’T WE HAD MAIL IN
BALLOTS FOR THE LAST 230 YEARS?
MAYBE THE REASON IS, IT’S AN
INVITATION TO WIDESPREAD FRAUD
AND MANIPULATION AND IF YOU WANT
TO RATTLE PEOPLE’S FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM WE’VE HAD FOR CENTURIES,
MAYBE YOU WOULD DO THAT.
I DON’T KNOW.
TOM HAS THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT IT.
SO IT’S JUST SO INTERESTING.
IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS PEOPLE
GRAVITATE TOWARDS SOLUTIONS THAT
MAKE YOU WONDER, PARTICULARLY
WHEN THEY ALL ALIGNED BEHIND ONE
SOLUTION.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER, WHY ARE
THEY ALL FOR IT?
MAYBE IT’S A GOOD IDEA AND MAYBE
IT’S NOT BUT WHY ARE THEY ALL
FOR IT?
>> I THINK THEY WANT TO SET UP A
SYSTEM THAT MAKES IT EASIER TO
STEAL ELECTIONS.
THERE ARE ALREADY WIDELY
AVAILABLE AMPS COMIC ABSENTEE
BALLOTS AND VOTING AND MADE
AVAILABLE TO AMERICANS AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD MAYBE BE MORE
WIDELY AVAILABLE IF THIS
CONTAGION CONTINUES IN THE FALL.
BUT I DON’T LIKE THAT BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE STATES, OR TOO MANY
OF THE STATES ACTUALLY REQUIRE
YOU TO SEND AN I.D. IN WITH YOUR
ABSENTEE BALLOT.
AND THEY WANT TO OVERTURN THAT.
SO THIS PLAN IS TO OVERTURN THE
VOTER I.D. LAWS IN 35 STATES,
HAVE MAILING -- WE JUST SUED IN
NORTH CAROLINA, ABOUT 1 MILLION
INACTIVE VOTERS.
MOST PEOPLE WHO HADN’T VOTED
SINCE LET’S SAY 2014.
SO ARE WE GOING TO START MAILING
AND ACTIVE VOTERS, PEOPLE WHO
DIED OR MOVED AWAY BALLOTS?
THAT’S AN OPEN INVITATION FOR
BALLOT FRAUD AND VOTER FRAUD.
THE SAFEST WAY TO VOTE IF YOU
WANT SECURE VOTING IS IN PERSON,
AND PRIVATE.
WHEN YOU TAKE THAT AWAY, IT’S
ANYTHING GOES.
AND OF COURSE THEY WANT TO ADD
BALLOT HARVESTING TO IT OR THEY
WOULD ALLOW THIRD PARTIES TO GO
AROUND AND BANGING ON DOORS AND
COLLECT BALLOTS.
WHAT A NIGHTMARE.
YOU KNOW, LOOK.
WE ARE DESTROYING OUR ECONOMY,
LIMITING OUR FREEDOMS AND THAT
WE WANT THEY WANT TO BLOW UP OUR
ELECTIONS AND WE CAN’T LET THAT
HAPPEN, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: CITIZENS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE.
BUT IF YOU CARE ABOUT DEMOCRACY,
YOU WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE’S
CONFIDENCE THAT IT’S REAL.
SO YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT